identity politics is not working quite
like it used to for the past 20 25 years
all the democrats needed to do
was throw the word racist at someone and
it would destroy that person okay and it
would make everyone cower and fear it's
the worst thing that you can possibly be
called
they would wield
woke identity politics to get whatever
they wanted it was a total get out of
jail free card
that is not working as well anymore and
i think someone who perfectly
exemplifies how little that is working
is chet hanks chet hanks is one of tom
hanks's sons he is one of my absolute
favorite figures in the culture uh he
talks kind of like a
rapper and he first came to my attention
at least uh when his parents got kovid
and and he he came on instagram and he
said hey y'all it's chet here yeah my
parents have covid crazy right and i
thought no the crazy thing is that you
are chet hanks what do you how is this
tom hanks's son and he's he's made jokes
about the vaccine and he's made jokes
about political correctness and the
culture and he just seems great i just
really like him as a cultural figure so
anyway uh chet hanks was talking to a
tick tock star
zee wee a woman with whom i was not
familiar before
z we asked chat if there are any
marginalized communities that just in
general he as a white man wants to
apologize to here's his answer
are there any marginalized communities
you want to apologize to i don't know
maybe the pothole community
no
i don't feel like i've truly done
anything offensive so
you don't see it as cultural
appropriation you see it as like a
celebration of culture
and then it's like social justice
warriors can like go kick rocks yeah
yeah
yeah
no comment got it no i mean i i 100
agree social justice warriors can kick
rocks hmm
it's not no comment z-way says okay so
you're just refusing to say no no i'm
not i'm not refusing to answer i am
fully answering they can kick rocks i
will not apologize for being a dude i
won't apologize for being a white guy i
haven't done anything wrong i'm i'm not
evil by virtue of
my race and sex it's not wrong that i
have adopted certain aspects of what you
are suggesting is a black culture or
some other kind of ethnic culture no
that's not wrong it's it's obviously a
catch-22 by the way for white guys here
because if you do adopt characteristics
of another culture
then you are accused of cultural
appropriation
but if you don't adopt traits of another
culture you're accused of cultural
erasure or eurocentrism or any of these
other kinds so you're damned if you do
and damned if you don't and he says look
i haven't done anything wrong i've just
spoken the truth as i see it i've
behaved in a way that i don't i don't
think is immoral i'm actually just
encouraging people to go sort of
exercise and you know think the right
things and so no i'm not gonna apologize
for anything sorry
um but but you you are a white man
i am yes and so but you're not going to
apologize for that uh no i don't i don't
think that i will why should he that
that would be so crazy that would be so
crazy and i'm glad that people finally
have the confidence again to say no
we're i'm just going to reject the whole
premise here
that we have this hierarchy of races and
certain races need to feel really bad
about themselves and other races are
they're the good races and this this
idea that men are just intrinsically
evil and awful and they got all no we're
not going to do any of that sorry
i'm glad you like that clip now ding
ding ding ring that bell subscribe get
all the notifications smash that button
whatever you know just leave a comment
or whatever and also check out the
michael knowles show at apple podcast
spotify stitcher google wherever you get
your audio podcasts we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]